i could
go to henry kissinger for a brief moment
and people should read this
op-ed he wrote in the washington post in
march 5th 2014
after the start of the war between
russia and ukraine but before crimea was
annexed
uh there's a lot of interesting
historical description about the
division within ukraine the corruption
within ukraine
that will if people read this article
will give context to
how incredible it is what zelensky was
able to accomplish in uniting the
country but i just want to comment
because henry kissinger is a interesting
figure in american history he opens the
article with in my life
i have seen four wars begun with great
enthusiasm and public support all of
which we did not know how to end and
from three of which we withdrew
unilaterally
the test of policy is how it ends
not how it begins
so he's giving this cold hard truth
that we get we go into wars excited
are able to send 40 billion dollars
financial aid military aid
our own men and women
but the excitement fades
twitter
outrage fades and then
a country that's willing to wait
patiently or is is willing to to pay the
cost of siege versus the cost of
explaining to its own people that the
war is lost that country just might win
outlast let's hope not
because
uh
ukrainians
resistance deserves to prevail here
russia deserves to lose
no war of aggression like they've
committed here against ukraine
should prevail if we can do anything
about it
i support a thousand percent
the continued
supply of heavy weapons including
offensive weapons to the ukrainians
as long as they're willing to resist and
it's their choice
it's their choice when to negotiate it's
their choice how much to resist it's
their choice what kind of sacrifices to
make
and it and it's our responsibility
to meet their requests more quickly
than we have so far and at greater scale
but ultimately wars only have political
ends
they never have military ends
you need a political solution here
so if the ukrainians are able
to conduct a successful
counter-offensive at scale
in july or august whenever they launch
right now the heavy weapons are coming
in
and they're being moved to the
battlefield and more are coming you know
the dynamic russia bombs a school
russia bombs a hospital
americans and europeans decide to send
even more heavy weapons to ukraine right
that's the self-defeating dynamic from
the russian side they commit the
atrocities we send more heavy weapons
once those heavy weapons are on the
battle lines
we'll see if ukrainians cannot just
defend
which they've proven they're able to do
in breathtaking fashion
not just conduct counter-attacks
where the enemy moves forward and you
cut behind the enemy's lines
and you counter attack and push the
enemy back a little bit
but whether you can evict
the russians from your territory with a
combined arms operation where you have a
massive superiority in in infantry and
heavy weapons but more importantly you
coordinate your air power
your tanks your drones your infantry
at scale
which is something the ukrainians have
not done yet it's something the russians
failed at in ukraine and they come from
the same place the soviet military
we hope this ukrainian counter-offensive
at scale this combined uh arms operation
succeeds
and if it does succeed there's the
possibility of a battlefield victory
whether that also includes crimea
which as you know is not hostile on the
contrary
to the russian military
remains to be seen
but but however much
they regain
territorially back towards the 1991
borders which is their goal their stated
goal
and which we support them properly in
trying to achieve
however much they achieve of that in
this counter offensive that we're
anticipating
that will set the stage for the next
phase
and either russia the which is to say
one person
vladimir putin
will acknowledge that he's lost the war
because the ukrainians want it on the
battlefield
or
he'll try to
announce a full-scale mobilization
conscript the whole country
go back and instead of acknowledging
defeat try to win with a different plan
recalibrate
remains to be seen
will the ukrainians negotiate any
territory away or must they capture also
crimea
which puts a very high bar
on the wind on the summer
counter offensive that we're going to
see which could last through the fall
and into the winter as a result
we don't know the answers to that nobody
knows the answers to that people are
guessing some people are better informed
because they have
inside intelligence
people are also worried about russian
escalation
to nuclear weapons or chemical weapons
if they begin to lose on the battlefield
to ukraine
you